written and directed by lee wannell the
invisible man is a rock solid thriller
but some of its mysteries are never
fully resolved
however we'll be breaking down all of
the questions that the film never gave
us answers to
to see if we can answer them ourselves
pretty much every scene in the invisible
man is about cecilia struggling
literally or metaphorically with
adrian's lingering presence in her life
the film's singular focus on this one
plot line is generally a good thing
since it offers the audience no escape
from the constantly escalating tension
but unfortunately it also means that
there's basically no room in the film
for subplots
so we don't get a chance to learn much
about who cecilia
is as a person outside of her
relationship with adrian
in the brief moments where cecilia is
momentarily free of adrian's grasp
we catch glimpses of a truly compelling
character who we want to learn more
about
when she james and sydney are just
hanging out together cecilia is sharp
funny and empathetic
also in one scene cecilia is suddenly
being interviewed for a job at an
architecture firm
the only acknowledgement we get of
cecilia having career aspirations
was she an architect before did she give
it up for adrian
one reason why cecilia sometimes feels
like such a cipher is because
even she herself might not even know who
she is anymore
trauma can make you feel like whoever
you once were that person has now been
erased you have no life outside your
struggle for
survival who was cecilia before she met
adrian
the film doesn't answer and we'd really
like to know
but perhaps cecilia is currently in a
place where not even she remembers from
the moment
emily rescues cecilia from adrian's
house something seems off about their
interactions
emily is never seen comforting her
sister most of their conversations
quickly turn to bickering
and most tragically of all when strange
things start happening to cecelia
emily doesn't take her sister's concerns
seriously
one possible interpretation of their
dynamic is that it's solely a necessary
plot device in order for the horror of
the film to function
as is the case with many horror stories
the scares can only continue if no one
listens to the protagonist
but there's also a more charitable
reading of their dynamic
long before cecilia escaped from adrian
she and emily were already estranged
think about it the way that cecilia
stalker drives a wedge between her and
emily is by sending
a single fake email telling emily that
cecilia wishes
she was dead what happens next emily
immediately cuts cecilia out of her life
cecilia denies that she sent the email
but emily refuses to listen
if that email was a wildly out of
character thing for cecilia to say
you'd think that emily would consider
the possibility that she didn't have the
full picture
and she'd listen to cecilia's
explanation emily's reaction only makes
sense if there was already some
underlying tension between the sisters
that cecelia's tormentor was exploiting
we never get the full story about the
reason for this tension
but some old wound is undeniably there
after cecilia is arrested for her
sister's murder
a nurse meets with her and tells her
that according to a blood test
cecilia is pregnant the nurse says
the test shows us that it was pretty
recent
can't be sure of exactly when but it
must have been some time in the last
month
so now comes an unpleasant question when
and how did cecilia get pregnant at this
point we don't know exactly how long
it's been since cecilia escaped from
adrian
two weeks passed between when she first
left and when she heard of his apparent
suicide
since then we're guessing that at least
a few more weeks have probably elapsed
if not significantly longer perhaps even
a couple months
it's possible though a bit of a stretch
that adrian got cecilia pregnant while
they were still living together
but it's also possible that and here's
where things get real uncomfortable
he did so after she'd already left we
don't want to think about the mechanics
of how exactly that would work
but given what we know about adrian both
in terms of his immorality
and his resourcefulness it's not out of
the question
one other lingering question that the
film doesn't answer is what's going to
happen to cecilia's unwanted pregnancy
we can understand why the film didn't go
there but whether or not cecilia plans
on keeping it is perhaps one of the
biggest questions that the film chooses
to leave
unanswered when cecilia finally shoots
the invisible assailant in james's house
and peels the suit off him
she's surprised to find not adrian
inside but rather
his simperine toad of a brother tom
there are a few different ways to
interpret this reveal
one is that tom really was the one
tormenting cecilia all this time
and adrian never got his hands dirty
personally another interpretation
is that this is the only time tom wears
the suit perhaps because adrian is
attempting to frame him but at all other
points adrian is the only one abusing
her
either one of these explanations are
potentially defensible
but there's another interesting option
it's also possible that
during the final invasion of james's
house and perhaps earlier there are two
invisible men tom and adrian working
together simultaneously
after all when sydney finally confronts
the invisible man in her room by macing
him
he collapses to the ground but then a
moment later when sydney runs out into
the hallway
she's immediately knocked over it's
possible that it's the same guy but the
logistics of the scene make way more
sense if there was actually a second
invisible man
waiting in the hallway we know that
adrian has access to multiple suits
and don't forget when adrian is
discovered by police the next day
his eyes look awfully red perhaps like
someone who was recently maced
throughout much of the film adrian and
his brother tom appear to be in a more
or less equal partnership
a unified front of awfulness but
occasionally we get hints that their
relationship might be a lot more
complicated
at one point tom asserts that adrian
held all the power in their relationship
saying my brother controlled me long
before he met you cecilia
later after tom is killed adrian claims
that the complete opposite is true
saying i know i didn't seem like it to
the outside world
tom controlled me if both brothers
claimed that they were the abused and
powerless party in a toxic relationship
who should we believe we feel the
evidence points towards tom being
subservient to adrian and not the other
way around
when tom visits cecelia and the psych
ward he tells her that they can get her
out of jail if she agrees to return to
her life with adrian
this ultimatum doesn't really make sense
if tom has the power and
adrian is just a puppet that being said
it's also potentially
true that both brothers are telling the
truth at least in part
maybe they each abused one another at
various times or perhaps both are lying
and their claims of abuse exist solely
to manipulate cecelia's emotions
regardless none of this justifies the
way that either of them behaves so it
also seems safe to just label them both
as irredeemable jerks and move on with
our lives
since there's still arguably a bit of
ambiguity at the end of the film
regarding just how bad of a guy
adrian is is cecilia's decision to
murder him truly justifiable
during adrian and cecilia's final dinner
conversation cecilia is wearing a wire
to record their conversation
presumably she's doing this to attempt
to trick adrian into confessing his
crimes on tape so that she can send him
to jail
adrian however is evasive and he starts
trying to seduce and gaslight cecilia
all over again
this culminates with him using the
phrase that shouldn't come as a
surprise as adrian says these words a
twinge of realization flashes across
cecilia's face
presumably because this has just
confirmed two things for her
the first comes from how he says that
word surprise in his deep raspy voice
that same word was used mockingly by
cecilia's invisible stalker as he was
tormenting her
and hearing that word again and adrian's
voice presumably confirms for her that
they are the same person
we can also assume that this confirms
for cecilia that adrian is still willing
to lie to her
willing to start up the cycle of abuse
all over again adrian truly has no
remorse
no conscience and he's never going to
stop that was enough for cecilia to
conclude that adrian needed to die
does that make what she did right in the
end cecilia decides to kill adrian by
putting on an invisibility suit and
forcing him to cut his own throat with a
knife
in full view of the house's security
cameras so that he appears to be
committing suicide
it's a shocking and gut-wrenching moment
but it also has the potential to be
somewhat confusing
after all the exact logistics of how
cecilia accomplished this plan
aren't ever fully explained when and how
exactly did she get her hands on an
invisibility suit of her own
one option is that cecilia is wearing
tom's suit for when he attacked james's
house
however this seems unlikely for two
reasons first
the suit was clearly damaged after
cecelia shot it to pieces
the second problem is that tomsute was
presumably turned over to the police as
evidence
what seems to be a far more likely
option is that cecilia's suit is
actually the one that she discovered
earlier in the basement when she crept
back into adrian's house
halfway through the film in this scene
she peels it off a mannequin
presumably to steal it but when she
hears someone entering the house
cecilia appears to stash the suit away
in an air vent inside adrian's closet
later when cecilia claims that she's
going to the bathroom during her dinner
with adrian
she's most likely retrieving the suit
from the closet and using it to execute
her master plan
after cecilia's final confrontation with
adrian the film
ends rather abruptly even though in this
moment cecilia seems to have found some
measure of closure
we still have endless questions about
what comes next for her
first is cecilia going to jail for any
of the stuff she's done
she may not have actually committed her
sister's murder but she did break out of
a mental hospital
and she did kill both tom and adrian
however we think she's going to be just
fine
numerous people saw an invisible suspect
menacing cecilia in the hospital
which means shooting tom was
legitimately self-defense
plus her plan for eliminating adrian was
rock solid
and if things go bad cecilia also just
inherited five million dollars
so she can probably afford some pretty
good lawyers
one of the reasons that the invisible
man has been so critically well received
is because it succeeds on numerous
different levels simultaneously
it's not just a vehicle for scares it's
also a film with a brain
full of deeper themes about trauma and
abuse but what exactly
is it trying to say about these subjects
first
in regards to trauma the film shows us
that even when the source of your pain
is gone
trauma stays with you like an invisible
monster
we see that this is the case for cecilia
even before the invisible man comes back
into her new life
she's afraid to leave the house she has
trouble sleeping and she jumps at
shadows
metaphorically cecelia's tormentor is a
personification of trauma
an invisible force that stands at the
foot of her bed at night
follows her down the street and pulls
her away from her friends and family
and second in regards to abuse the
invisible man shows us that when people
come forward and claim that they're
being abused we tend not to believe them
we downplay their stories invalidate
their feelings
and call them crazy pretty much everyone
in the film does this to cecilia at some
point
even her sister and her friend this film
is a reminder that just because we can't
see the people around us being abused
that doesn't mean it isn't happening
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
horror movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one